okay in this video we're talking about
is the triangle an isoceles right
triangle given the vertices 2 comma 21
-2 and
35 so how can we tell whether this is
going to be an isos right triangle or
not well I sketched it out just to kind
of get a rough idea about what this
looks like and so you can see we've got
a triangle something like this and I
just labeled the vertices M A and R so
we know an ises triangle
at least two of the sides are congruent
and we know a right triangle we know it
has a 90° angle and we also know that if
it's a right triangle that it will
satisfy the Pythagorean theorem meaning
a^2 + b^2 is equal to c^2 so let's keep
that in mind so we're trying to figure
out are two of the sides congruent that
makes it isoceles and does it satisfy
the Pythagorean theorem that makes it a
right triangle so in order to do this
we're going to have to use the distance
formula and you might remember from a
previous class the distance formula is
this guy right here it's the difference
in the x coordinates
squared plus the difference in the Y
coordinates squared and then you take
the square root and that's going to give
you the distance between you know two
points on our graph so let's go ahead
and start off by finding the distance
from M to a so I'm just going to call
that M A and it's the square Ro T of 2 -
-1
squared
plus 2 -
-2 squared and let's see what this comes
out to so when you subtract it's like
adding the opposite so we have 3^ S
which is 9 and 4^ SAR which is 16 and
this is 25 the square of 25 is equal to
5 okay so that's the length of ma right
here so let's just try to sketch this in
roughly something something like this
and we say this is five okay now let's
do uh AR right here so a
r same thing distance formula the square
< TK of 3 - -1
2ar and -5 -
-2 squared add those together take the
square root so this comes out to 4^ 2
which is
16 -32 which is
so again you can see we have theare of
25 which is equal to 5 so that tells us
that this is indeed isoceles because we
have these two sides uh congruent and
what about this third side here uh Mr
let's go ahead and find that
length so again the square root of 3 -
2^ 2 just subtracting the x coordinates
and
squaring and5 -
squar so that's 1 SAR which is 1 -7 SAR
which is 49 and that comes out to the
square root of 50 now we can simplify
that but for right now let's just leave
it as a square root of 50 what we're
asking ourselves is does this satisfy
the Pythagorean theorem is a^2 + b^2 =
to c^2 well let's double check so we've
got 5 SAR + 5^ SAR question mark does
that equal the square Ro T of 50 squared
5^ s is 25 + 5^ S is 25 and sare of 50
squar the square and the square root
cancel so you can see we're getting 50
is equal to 50 so that tells us that it
satisfies the Pythagorean theorem which
means that this is going to be a right
angle here so in this case we would say
yes this is
a an isoceles right triangle now there's
another way to do this problem you could
do the slope of ma and the slope of a r
and if they're opposite reciprocals of
each other that would tell you that this
is a right angle but in this case we
just used the Pythagorean theorem so
great job if you're able to follow this
example I'll see you over in some of my
other videos